In a nuclear reactor, there are three primary barriers to radiation release.
The first is the fuel assembly.
The Zircaloy rods around the fuel protect from the release of radioactive material.
The second is the pressure vessel which surrounds the core...
...that also prevents the release of radioactive material.
The third is the containment structure surrounding the entire reactor.
The containment structure prevents the uncontrolled release of radioactive material from the reactor.
Now, the entire structure is designed to withstand a multitude of natural disasters...
...including tornado, earthquake, fire, flood, tsunami, hurricanes as well,...
...and the storm surge associated with those facilities.
And the facility, to give you an idea of some of the design things that we incorporate,...
...the picture shown here has a picture of a building that contains a diesel generator.
The intake structure for the diesel generator where the air comes in to supply the diesel...
...is raised above ground at about 25 to 30 feet off...
...to protect it from any storm surge that might occur from a hurricane for example.
The surrounding equipment at ground level is not essential to maintaining the ability to safely shut down the facility.